in this episode of the roadside MBA we
visit the Rosa brothers milk company in
central California hey who's ever milked
a cow before where we get our hands
dirty on the farm oh yeah now she's got
it oh yeah that's good stuff
find out what root beer-flavored milk
tastes like oh that's good oh that's
really good and learn why product
differentiation is the key to helping
your small business stand out in a
crowded commodity market where you have
to convince your customers to pay more
to survive
we're on the road heading south from San
Francisco three economics professors
leaving our day jobs behind off on a
journey into California's agricultural
heartland
this area that we're in the middle of
now is called the Central Valley of
California it's full of dairy farms
this is Tulare County the dairy industry
here brings in as much as 1.8 billion
dollars a year more than any other
county in the United States we've come
to find out what it takes to make it in
the milk business Rawlins Rosa's a
third-generation dairy farmer he and his
brother Knoll inherited the family farm
16 years ago so thanks for coming out
are you guys interested in the full tour
or just kind of already in it we're
ready in a tour we're ready for a tour
we want to see some see some dairy cows
some cows hey we've got 28 cows here
well it takes us to the milking barn
where the production process begins okay
who's ever milked a cow before milking
the cow wasn't my favorite thing that I
did today there's a teat canal there so
you want to grab at the top and kind of
push the milk down then it'll come out I
was nervous when I was milking the cow I
thought I might get kicked
it went smoother than I thought milk
actually came out which I was a bit
surprised then you put the vacuums on
each of the teats and the rest is sort
of vacuumed or sucked out do it - it
kind of simulates what you're doing with
your hand so those pulses of milk go
through and go through a sensor and then
goes into the pipeline I always sort of
wondered you know how did they get all
that milk that they you know even had in
the production area how do they get all
that milk well now I understand because
those cows are ball next he shows us
where all those full-grown cows come
from this is the area where the calves
are born
that's a calf that was just born this
morning just this morning right Wow
I also really like seeing the baby cow
that was kind of cute wasn't it calves
have just huge eyes it was kind of
looking up at me wondering why I was
there so first thing you want to do if
you're gonna feed it you want them to be
standing up so they can yeah swallow
prop it up little guy so you have to
reach your fingers into the cow's mouth
very sharp teeth and then following
behind that you have to come in with the
bottle there we go
you would think the cow would be hungry
right this is a cow that has to grow so
it needs to eat but yet you kind of had
to convince it look at that had to
happen squirting some milk into the
cow's mouth forcibly would show the cow
that this is a good place to get it
music oh yeah she's got it oh yeah
that's good stuff
Roland and his brother Knoll enjoy being
farmers but they say it can be a hard
way to make a living the state of
California sets the price for milk we're
all going to get the same price no
matter what processor we go to the state
sets a minimum price and that's all the
processors pay in 2009 we saw a
situation where our input cost really
went up and the value of our product
completely went down and that there was
such a disparity there there was no way
that any dairy farm in California was
going to survive and so it was a
situation where you realize you can't
run a business like that we have to have
some control over the product pricing a
couple years ago they said okay how can
we separate ourselves how can we
differentiate ourselves from all these
other dairy farmers around here and they
said let's move down the vertical chain
of production
let's vertically integrate forward into
producing milk rather than just taking
it out of cows and selling it to big
processors we're going to process it
ourselves and have actual milk that we
are going to sell to consumers
so they built their own milk processing
plant okay so I have a large and
extra-large
Knowles join us around we had to put on
a ridiculous play clothing I am a doctor
so this is appropriate attire you're a
doctor of economics that's different we
had to wash our hands after you dry your
hands sanitize we had to step through
with our shoes some sort of foot bath of
disinfectant and all that's to make sure
that nothing is getting into the milk
bottles
except for though
really this is Paul Scott and Mike
they'd like to know how you make that
milk their facility is much smaller than
many of the other milk factories around
here which means the production costs
are significantly higher than the
competitors so they needed to find a way
to convince customers to pay more with
their milk of course that's difficult
unless you have some way of presenting a
different value proposition some way of
not being just another gallon plastic
milk in that refrigerator you can't make
any money doing that if you just make
milk the way the other guys make it so
they said let's try to figure out a way
we can do that and sell it at a higher
price and they figured out a way and
it's by making the milk in glass bottles
we researched this for a couple of years
and part of our research was my brother
went online and found farms that were
bottling their own milk across the
country and I visited dairies that were
in plastic jugs and visited areas that
were in glass and what I found was the
guys who were in plastic were really
struggling to differentiate the product
and so in the end what they ended up
doing was they ended up competing with
the big store brands on price so Nolan
Rowan decided to offer their milk in
glass bottles rather than plastic if
consumers preferred the taste of milk
bottled in glass recognized glass
bottles as a symbol of quality they
could charge a higher price and still
sell milk the key to differentiation for
Rosen brothers was the glass bottle the
glass bottle was a symbol to customers
that the product was different and the
Proud was better so what we have here is
our filler machine the bottles will come
in here as the bottles are push up
against the rubber boot there it opens
the flow the milk flows into the bottles
and then the bottle will come over here
and then as it gets to the end of the
line we'll have a person take the bottle
off of the line
so this is our skim milk partially
filled bottle coming off of the line why
don't you give it a taste
you have any cereal this is where all
those bottles come to be cleaned before
the milk goes in washing room this
machine takes them through a hot water
caustic bath and then it does a series
of rinses sanitizer and the bottles come
out clean they go directly onto the
conveyor and directly to be refilled
Noelle put us to work washing bottles
but as we loaded the washer we wondered
why can't the big milk processor just
put their milk into glass bottles and
selling at a low price
putting Rosa brothers out of business
turns out their factories are too big
one broken bottle would be a disaster
everyone that I spoke to in the industry
prior to us starting our plant when I
mentioned glass in a food processing
facility they just said no way because
if you have a large processing facility
you have multiple lines if one glass
shard were to fly from this line and it
could contaminate thousands of bottles
of milk we have one line if there was a
problem we could stop the line and we
could clear everything out easily
how did you get distribution into the
supermarkets that was the big hurdle the
supermarket's didn't want to talk to us
they're like we don't want to have to
handle those bottles coming back we were
so glad when Coke quit doing that years
ago and we don't want to go back to
those days and we have our own milk
processing plant major supermarkets have
their own milk processing plant so that
they can supply their own stores they
said we've you use competition we don't
want anything to do with you so we got
the door slammed in our face
okay multiple times so they started
selling their milk directly to consumers
we went to farmers markets and did
tastings started selling at farmer's
markets to kind of build this grassroots
campaign so we were out there at the
farmers markets talking about it and
people say well why can't we buy this in
the grocery store ask for it we put on
the side of our distribution trucks ask
for it at your local grocer then they
got their big break then we went to a
Food Show and we won new product of the
year we got a lot of press with that and
so a lot of people were talking about
our products so then we got the call
from some of the major retailers yeah we
need to talk to you so that groundswell
of people pressuring the dairy manager
who then pressured the store manager who
then pressured the district manager who
then went to corporate said we need this
product in our store
another way Rosa brothers milk stands
out from the competition
is its unique flavors okay guys do we
have flavor samples chocolate root beer
float orange cream milk does taste
better when it's fresh it also tastes
better when you put a lot of sugar in it
orange cream tastes like a 50/50 bar so
the sherbet with the vanilla ice cream
meal time to revisit a sweet taste from
childhood this tastes exactly the way
you described it out if my wife knew
this existed I would have to buy it all
the time this tastes like the last sip
of a root beer float oh that's good oh
that's really good
the root beer is delicious the milks I
knew you could tell that they tasted a
little bit better because of the glass
bottle but the variety of different
flavors
those milks were distinct and that's
really key and a differentiation
strategy to make sure your products are
sufficiently distinct so that if you
find the people that really get a kick
out of orange creamsicle milk well then
I've got something that definitely
appeals to them and we can make a match
now he's gonna get the cream and put in
the correct number of gallons they also
use the excess cream that's a byproduct
of making low-fat milk to make ice cream
I'd like to try coconut and chocolate
this is the one that tastes like an
almond joy bar the ice cream tastes
great oh this is delicious
I could sit here and eat that the rest
of the day
this is like my ideal this is awesome I
have the pistachio ice cream which was
excellent I would buy that if it were
available where I live
Noelle says they use all natural
ingredients and they don't use
preservatives like the big manufacturers
because they don't have to ship their
ice cream so far but we think that Rosa
brothers might have a harder time
competing in the ice cream market
against the likes of Ben and Jerry's and
haagen-dazs it's harder to differentiate
yourself in terms of packaging with ice
cream than with milk there are already
established competitors in that space so
I think that's the fun story to follow
over the next few years about Rosa
brothers is what's going to happen with
ice cream side so let me ask the final
final question if we drive by back if we
were stupid enough and drive out this
way if we drive down K Street or
wherever you are at downtown Tulare five
to ten years from now what are we gonna
say I think it's gonna look exactly the
same but some of those buildings along K
Street that don't have any signs will
probably be additional warehousing and
additional facilities for us and in my
Palo Alto grocery store am I gonna see
Rosa brothers by five ten years from now
yes
all right we have that on tape we've had
fun hanging out with the Rosa brothers
but now it's time to say goodbye and get
back on the road
we're headed south to Adelanto
California a small city on the edge of
the Mojave Desert where we're hoping to
find American manufacturing alive and
well in a place you might least expect
them